palestinians as an occupied people have
the right to defend themselves
by all feasible means not by firing
rockets from a civilian population
i have said it clearly moral equivalence
up the wazoo and also it's about
anti-semitism and also islamophobia
man so meanwhile the biden
administration they are making some of
the right moves they are saying some of
the right things
so for example the the biden
administration joe biden put out a
statement today he said the recent
attacks on the jewish community are
despicable and they must stop i condemn
this hateful behavior at home and abroad
it's up to all of us to give hafe
hate no safe harbor so good for him
that's an actual statement as opposed to
all the rest of these pathetic democrats
who are putting out statements about
anti-semitism and
islamophobia again it's it's a pretty
incredible thing from the same people
who are very concerned about the phrase
all lives matter
right when someone say black lives
matter and somebody else would say allah
is my big how dare you you're devaluing
our movement
the same people are like anti-semitism
and islamophobia now at least all lives
matter
was rejecting the basic contention that
black people were being specifically
singled out
for harsh treatment by the police with
regard to being murdered by the cops
okay that's a statistical reality but
when it comes to anti-semitism there's a
radical uptick in anti-semitism and
these same democrats like yeah and also
islamophobia
which is the same way they shied away
from elhenom being a radical anti-semite
last year
when they were like we condem
anti-semitism and also all these other
forms of hatred and everything bad in
the universe
baffling with bullcrap anyway the biden
administration saying the right things
on anti-semitism the biden
administration
suggesting israel had a right and a duty
to protect itself last week so they did
a lot better on this than i thought they
were going to
meanwhile however they are indeed
pursuing bad policy with regard to the
iranian regimes the iran
regime is the the state it is the
sponsor state of hamas
hamas admits that they got all of their
technology from iran
and hamas acknowledges that that iran
backed them
and in fact iran cheered the attacks
according to the new york times
tehran jumped at the chance to portray
militants barrages on israel as revenge
for israeli attacks on iran
the leadership of iran engaged in a long
shadow war with israel on land aaron c
did not try to conceal the pleasure it
took in the most recent
israeli-palestinian conflict
tehran praised the damage being done to
its enemy state news media and
conservative commentators highlighted
iran's role
in providing weaponry and military
training to palestinian militants in
gaza to hammer israeli communities so
iran is making no
no bones about the fact that it supports
hamas meanwhile hamas is acknowledging
that they openly commit war crimes
right here is hamas's spokesperson on
sky news basically saying yeah sure we
commit war crimes
any people under occupation based on the
international law have
the all the right to defend themselves
by
all feasible means they have not by
firing rockets from a civilian
population
i have said it clearly palestinians as
an occupied people have the right to
defend themselves
by all feasible means including our
resistance but when it comes
to civilians we have said that many
times we are ready to stop
firing rockets or attacking civilians if
this
is stopped attacking our people it's
unbelievable so he's saying openly right
this is
the spokesperson remember this is this
is the government that people are
supporting
when you say i support the palestinians
and the palestinian-israeli conflict
you don't mean the palestinian people
unless you also want to get rid of hamas
but you don't want to get rid of hamas
so what am i left to conclude
okay they're openly saying that they
fire rockets from civilian areas at
civilians
they say this sort of stuff openly
they're not hiding the ball here
meanwhile even despite the ceasefire
hamas supporters were attacking jewish
homes outside jerusalem over the weekend
there's video of it they were literally
just firing ordinance down
from arab areas near jerusalem into the
jewish areas of jerusalem
you can see it happening they're
shooting fireworks at the jewish areas
in jerusalem
unreal
[Music]
don't worry there's moral equivalence
you shoot you shoot randomly rockets at
uh an ordinance at jewish homes right
these are civilians you're not military
targets
shouting allahu akbar that's exactly the
same as the israelis targeting
military infrastructure in any case how
has the the
biden administration responded to the
fact that hamas an iran-backed terrorist
group
just committed a vast act of terrorism
against america's ally israel
uh blinken says we have to cut a deal
with iran here's tony blinken the
secretary of state
many of these actions are going forward
now uh while the uh you know and have
gone forward over the last few years
under the so-called maximum pressure uh
being exerted
by the by the previous administration
and clearly did not get the result that
we all seek
which is to curb all of these activities
but the first thing that we need to do
is put the nuclear problem back in the
box that's why we're committed to trying
to
see if iran will come back into
compliance with the nuclear agreement
the so-called jcpoa
that's what we're engaged in now the lie
that the biden administration is talking
about here
is they say well if we get them back in
the nuclear box we'll stop them from the
terrorism except that's not what they do
okay the jcpoa did not stop iran from
formatting terrorism how do you think
hamas got all these rockets hamas was
having its stockpiles built up more
rapidly
before trump pulled out of the jcpoa
then after
the jcpoa was ended and hamas
hamas all these terrorist groups get
support from iran when iran has more
money they spend the money on terrorism
john kerry admitted
as much after cutting the iran deal in
the first place well israel understands
that it has to rely on itself in large
measure here which is why there was a
giant blast
an iranian complex housing their drone
factory so israel shot down
in iranian armed drone the other day and
mysteriously a complex that houses a
factory that makes iranian drones
now suffered a major explosion the blast
at the weekend in
over the weekend injured at least nine
workers at the petrochemical factory
in isfahan iran aircraft manufacturing
industrial company which produces a
variety of aircraft and drones
for iranian and pro-iranian forces is
located in the complex
iran has not provided information on the
cause of the incident but
israel of course has carried out
significant strikes internal to iran
meanwhile
speaking of the the supposed
non-radicalism of
palestinians on the temple mount
remember according to ilhan omar and
rashida talib and everyone else lying
about the situation in israel
this is all kicked off by israelis
attacking palestinians on the temple
mount which is insane
and i've been up on the temple mount
jews have to be guarded
by police forces as they are ushered
through the holiest site in judaism
meanwhile arabs have free reign on the
temple mount because it is effectively
run
by the islamic walk al-aqsa was being
used as a staging ground for attacks on
jewish police officers
so even after this there's a vast video
emerging like
after the ceasefire of people attacking
police officers on the temple mount in
fact
videos on social media have shown
believe it or not
that members of the hundreds of
palestinians inside
the al-aqsa mosque were were cheering
the the for they forced out the
jerusalem grand mufti okay the jerusalem
grand mufti is getting mohammed hussein
he works for the palestinian authority
hey and supporters inside al-aqsa
forced him to leave while shouting we
are
muhammad df's men muhammad df is the
terror head of hamas
they're chatting they're chanting this
inside a mosque a very peaceful and
religious place
i remember the last time inside a a
synagogue we started chanting for
support of terrorism but
apparently this is common practice
inside al-aqsa these days
so they're chanting about how they are
muhammad deif's men
don't worry everything is fine
everything and you know what moral
equivalence
up to wazoo and also it's about
anti-semitism and also islamophobia
man you know it's it's there are certain
conflicts in uh in ideology
where things sort of crystallize and
honestly if you have a tough time with
this one i've got to question your moral
bona fides if you have a real tough time
questioning the difference between
an israeli government that attempts to
minimize civilian casualties and a hamas
government that attempts to maximize
them
between an israeli population that is
attempting to co-exist with an
internal israeli arab population and
treat those israeli arabs as full
citizens with full rights
and an arab world that treats jews not
only as second-class citizens but i mean
jews do not exist effectively speaking
inside the arab world
and inside the muslim world more
specifically if you are somebody who has
a tough time just saying anti-semitic
attacks are bad regardless of
the source of the anti-semitic attacks i
do have to question
your ability to perform basic moral math
and the democratic party increasingly
cannot perform basic moral math good for
joe biden for at least doing some of it
but i fear that joe biden is not the way
of the democratic party future
i was there in 2012 when when antonio
veragosa who was heading up the
democratic national convention
actively overrode a voice vote and
allowed the the
democratic national committee platform
to include
the idea that jerusalem was was the
capital of the jewish state
i was there when when he basically there
was a voice vote on it he lost the voice
would he just overrode them
i remember this vividly and now you have
200 democrats
who voted in the house not to cut off
funding to groups that fund hamas
so yeah the future of the democratic
party does look a lot more like
the squad and like jamal bowman and like
aoc
and like ilhan omar and rashida talib in
terms of their anti-semitic attacks
on the jewish state and by extension a
certain level of tacit support for
anti-semites in the united states
and sometimes not so tacit i mean aoc
was meeting with with jeremy corbyn
i fear for the f people talk about they
fear for the future of the republican
party because of trump and
authoritarianism and all this
the the party that that i fear right now
is not the republican party and it is
not close when it comes to being a jew
in america
the party i fear is the party that has
been poo pooing playing up
and and minimizing the impact of
anti-semitism
in the united states that is a scary
scary thing as a jew living in the
united states who wears yamaka proudly
and will continue
to do so how's this for a title ben
shapiro show subscriber destroys
like button with clicks and logic i'd
watch that make it happen gang